memorial day is a special observance for
americans we honor those who made the
ultimate sacrifice for our country
the flags in tradition at arlington
national cemetery is one event in which
members of the military honor their
fallen comrades each year ahead of
memorial day weekend old guard soldiers
place american flags at more than 228
thousand headstones my colleague brett
bear talked with joint chiefs chairman
general mark milley last week ahead of
that event
general thanks for the time hey brett
thanks thanks for having me why
is it important uh to be here
really any day but especially on
memorial day yeah i mean i think that we
should honor our veterans and our fallen
every day of the year and to be thankful
and
be on our knees thanking god that we had
these young men and women who gave their
all gave their tomorrows for our days
and
today is the one day of the year
that we celebrate that that we remember
it as an official holiday of the of the
nation but really it should be an
everyday thing we're in section 34
which is significant to you too sure
yeah and right here in section 34 we've
got some of the folks who raised the
flag on iwo jima right over your left
shoulder is the iwo jima memorial
my father landed on iwo jima we've got
general pershing here from world war one
and you know you got the book ends of
probably the worst 50 years or 30 years
really of violence in in human history
from 1914 to 1945 and
um that's a very very special time to
remember especially now with what's
going on in the world and we'll go over
to section 60 which is really
afghanistan iraq and you've you have
people here who have been buried who
served under your command
i do i absolutely do and i'll go
visit some of them and it's a it's a
very emotional moment for me
so
yeah i've got i'm very very proud of the
the troops that are here
and my soldiers are buried here as well
do you think most americans fully
appreciate
the sacrifice of the million
plus
who fought and died for our country
oh absolutely i do
i think the american people are
incredibly generous and
uh very appreciative of our military uh
they
uh i i think they absolutely uh are
thankful for the men and women who
served in our in the cloth of the nation
from the revolutionary war into today i
think the american people are very
appreciative of their military
i want to ask you some questions about
today's news and obviously there's a lot
of focus on ukraine and the one question
i get time and time again is
how does this end
i think right now it's a bit early to
actually tell and now you've got a very
significant operational fight going on
in the donbass between the ukrainian
and the russian militaries
how that shapes up in the next few weeks
will probably in large part shape the
outcomes
of what will happen it could end up as a
grind and go on and on and a stalemate
it could end up with one side or the
other
having a decisive victory it could end
up in a peace negotiation there's many
many alternatives and we're not really
sure right now it's up to ukrainians you
said at a news conference last week the
end state's defined by the political
leadership in in in this case president
valencia is going to define the end
state inside the boundaries of ukraine
so does that mean you're going to
support if he wants to let's say take
back crimea from the russians we the
military will support whatever you know
president biden in our political
leadership determines uh but in large
respect i mean this is a war between
ukraine and russia how this ends on the
battlefield is going to be determined by
president salinsky and the
in president putin if like for example
the ukrainians decide to use u.s
provided weapons against the russians in
russian territory i know there's a
policy thing but is that a problem for
us
well i think there's always a
possibility of escalation and we have to
closely manage escalation and the
chances of escalation so we do that and
that's why you saw secretary austin talk
to his counterpart that's why you saw me
talk to my counterpart in order to
manage escalation and prevent this thing
from expanding into something much more
horrific than it already is do you think
putin needs an off-ramp or
are you concerned that humiliating him
would cause some kind of catastrophic
result whether putin has an offer up or
not and whether zielinski has an offer
but not
those are up to those two leaders to
determine they've lost well over a
hundred thousand casualties killed and
wounded on both sides
there's been seven million refugees six
million uh internally displaced persons
horrific damage to the infrastructure of
ukraine in only 90 days this is a very
very serious war that's taken place with
high consumptions of of resources on
both sides
so i think a negotiated outcome is a
logical choice but both sides have to
come to that conclusion on their own we
mentioned section 60 and the veterans
from iraq and afghanistan buried here
looking back through the prison of
history to that time do you think that
we as a country got bogged down in iraq
and afghanistan when really the bigger
threat was china and his china
well there's no question that we you
know fought for 20 years in iraq and
afghanistan again a kind of insurgency
threat
against guerrillas and terrorists and in
in some ways those fights are still
going on terrorism hasn't gone away from
the face of the earth but at the same
time in parallel to those while we were
in iraq and afghanistan china was
building a world-class military and
russia was reforming itself and
preparing for the invasion that they're
executing right now
so bogged down sure i think that we were
clearly engaged and decisively engaged
in both of those conflicts while russia
and china were moving in a different
direction in that region north korea
sable rattling again firing three
missiles last week
talking very aggressively do you
consider that a serious threat as of
today sure north korea is very much a
serious threat they've got significant
capability they've got a very large land
army they've got a capable
missile and nuclear force and that is of
concern to us that's why we have 28 500
troops on the canary peninsula right now
today of course we have a
treaty a defense pact with south korea
and with japan will the regime last
forever no no regime lasts forever so at
some point
my thought is that
korea will once again be a unified
country at some point in the future how
far how it happens when it happens who
knows is the military in your mind ready
for the future
we're moving in that direction i think
that we've got a lot of work to do we're
in a
period of what i call a change in the
character of war where we have uh
fundamental changes in technology for
example robotics and artificial
intelligence this
last series of strategies have been put
out in the last few years are pointing
us in the direction
to adjust and reform our military the
country's divided but it seems the
military is grounding you know there's a
unifying factor with the u.s military do
you see it that way in a divided country
absolutely i mean you're sitting right
here on hallowed ground this is what
unifies us it's those that came before
us and this is where we come from and
we're never going to turn our backs on
the constitution we're not going to turn
our backs on those that are buried here
in arlington and that's what you think
about when you come here absolutely
every time
general thanks for the time great thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else